[Music]
trolls World Tour is about a lot of
things first and foremost it's about
music and the power of music music is
called the universal language for a
reason it can make you feel just about
anything but how do we tell that story
of the power of music well we tell it
through the message of harmony and
diversity I knew going into the second
movie that there was gonna be a lot more
music and that was gonna be really
exciting we have so many different
genres of music that we needed to have
authentic musicians and legends be a
part of this cast every time we were
able to get someone to come to the
studio and pitch the movie to them they
said yes in the room how it was great
working with all these different artists
and musicians you got people like George
Clinton
Mary Jane Anson Peck I wanted to meet
him anyway we had Gustavo Dudamel as
Patrol's Arts Osborn Kelly Clarkson
Anthony Ramos it's like intimidating in
the best way like are you sure you don't
want Kelly Clarkson's interesting all
the songs I got to go wash what you
called music out of my ears
you have singers like that you don't
have to do much directing
[Music]